it's funny i remember saying
because i said there needs to be a scene
and so much of it runs together for me
this was so long ago but i said there
needs to be a scene where
i'm on the phone like i i need there
needs to be a reaction
of of her oh it was a phone call because
she finds out on a phone call and i said
i i need that my side of that
and vince was like we were gonna shoot
it like this it was gonna be you know
stylized thing and they said
i i just really feel like
i i want her to have that
and they were like okay we're gonna
shoot it we don't know if we're gonna
use it we may stick with plan
a and then but they ended up
using a review you see her and then i i
think also then the day that we shot it
i had no expectations and i just wanted
to
go in and um
this scene prior where walt calls and
he's
on the phone with skylar
and i and there's no word from hank and
i'm like
what's happening and i haven't heard
anything from him and
i she's aware then because she there's
you know just a current of
worry because his job is dangerous and
she knows this
and now that we all kind of know what's
going on and
um it you know raises the stakes even
more
again such good television even when
you're in it you're aware
you're like the bad um
and i just really you know
love that they respected me enough to
shoot that and then that they that we
did end up
using it um but when i found out
that when she gets that news
i think it was more shock
at the immeasurable loss
and i think there's a moment of how can
i go on
and i don't want to and then i think she
really
like she gets her [ __ ] together you know
she gets rid of the purple she gets
because there's just like there's
nothing left to do that for anymore i
think it just
you know um she finally got it and
i i had someone ask me once if i thought
marie
killed herself after the show and i said
absolutely not
because she knows he would never want
her to do that
you